antonio sends it off 3-0 with the sub 3
era so the d-backs here with two on
nobody out for starling
there's a slider right there story
smothers it
they get one and they can't turn two
calhoun is home and the diamondbacks
have the game's first run and the early
lead for your diamondback starting
pitcher the right-hander luke weaver
he's made three starts and has yet to
complete the requisite five innings
garrett hampson the centerfielder
leading it off
check to swing at 96. and luke gets his
first strikeout
that'll bring up eduardo escobar
here's the 1-2 and he got him down and
able to slide it such an improved slider
first strike out of the ball game here's
vogue just like that yep two strikeouts
and a one two three nice bounce back
nola narano will lead things off
here this ball is drilled deep left
center field take a good look you won't
see it for long nolan is coming on he
has tied up the ball game with home run
number five the pitches that nolan was
missing
last week he's not missing this week
jake lamb sends a kicks and comes back
2-2 and that is the pitch that he's got
three straight strikeouts on escobar
vote jake lamb back foot slider
marte is eight for 15 lifetime against
senza
well that one was a beauty another
strikeout on that slider down and in
starling martin
starling hits one deep and gone say
goodbye starling martay that's his
second
and it's 2-1 diamondbacks
just kind of rolls up there not sharp
like his slider that one just hung right
over the inside part of the plate and
starling marte put a charge on
it so here's mcmahon he struck out
swinging in the second
high fly ball deep left field
going back and look it up flying out
three run home run
mcmahon
with a three-run jack to put the rockies
up four to two
for the slumping mcmann he gets the
green light three and up and it pays off
love it
sometimes you just have to trust your
player
vote leads off the fifth against antonio
senzatela vote struck out his first time
pops it up
center field should be easy for hillary
well
that ball is going to fall in front of
him and votes into second base
i'm watching the outfielder
he went back and then all of a sudden he
came trying in he never saw the baseball
nick now seven for 18 with four rbis
against senzatello over one this
afternoon
got the slider one more time trying to
dunk it out there in left center and it
drops in here comes vote rbi for ahmed
make it 4-3
committed second two down four could
tell marty who has singled and struck
out
there's a ground ball and hit sharply
into right field to base it i'm at
around third here comes the throw to the
plate and safe and on the play on the
throw in
katel marte takes sega we're nodded at
four starling martay has knocked in two
runs
reaches out and pokes it up the middle
and that one gets through here comes
cattell
third rbi today for starling marte and
it's five for diamondbacks
rockies have some work to do after the
diamondbacks scored three runs in the
top of the fifth inning back to work
nolan
nolan drives this ball high in the air
left center field he's got another one
he ties it up at five
his sixth of the year
and i'm telling you he's a suspicion an
eighth of an inch from having a
three-homer game
[Applause]
so here is starling bases full no outs
tied at five in the seventh oh he got a
hangar
high chopper arenado can't make the bare
hand play ahmed scores and it's six to
five another rbi for starling martay
his fourth this afternoon
here's david peralta oh for three well
calhoun is at third katel marty at
second starling marty at first
got it out over the plate at 97 that's
gonna get to the wall and here we go
calhoun is home
cattell will score here comes starling
the freight trains got a three-run
double yeah
and here's escobar oh for three
reaches out and pokes that one through
this will get peralta home
here comes the freight train and he's
just in there escobar hustles into
second ninth man to bat in the seventh
is jake lamb jake over three to start at
first base today
swinging a ground ball up to first and
by
the first baseman off his glove into
right field mcmahon escobar will score
and that makes it a six-run seventh
inning and an 11-5 diamondbacks lead
they bat around in the seventh nick
ahmed started this inning with a single
and ahmed sends one out to deep center
field nick ahmed it's over the head of
hilliard lamb's on the run they're going
to send him around third base jake will
score ahmed's got an rbi double
calhoun will be the 11th man to bat in
this inning
that one will get through nick ahmed
will take the turn
throw is cut off another rbi for cole
calhoun that's his third hit and it's 13
to five
[Applause]
trevor is single in a double at four at
bats
2-2
and trevor with another base hit he'll
drive home hampson
trevor is gonna long-stride it towards
second you're never gonna get him
nolan homer deep fly ball homer pop out
and if that's fair it's extra bases it's
plenty fair
it's going to be a double for nolan
trevor trots home
13-7
here's story who has single twice in
double
fastball hit to ahmed they get one
and they roll it nicely done by jake
lamb over there diamondbacks win the
ball game they take two of three
from the first place rockies